look around you
what makes you believe you're not just a
weapon
to achieve his end enough
[Music]
join our cause will be made
to serve right now
you hold all the power
make your choice sylvanas windrunner
despite all our efforts the mall
continues to grow what if dinathius's
treachery is irreparable
the primus is lost and bastion cannot
save the shadow lands alone
none of this should have happened
perhaps the winter queen could
my archon a living soul
seeks an audience a mortal
a king
by all our measures one who has spent
his life
striving for justice
one who would give anything to serve
his people
[Music]
one whose heart is true
very well he may approach
step forward
[Music]
my ascended have spoken of you
the king held captive in the mall
that prison could not hold me forever
why have you come to bastion
you have a key that i need
[Music]
you will release this soul
from your grasp no
he is bound to me just as
you would sought to buy your own
brother
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
the vessel performed its part
flawlessly
[Music]
three keys
then they will see
death was never meant
to be chained
you dare enter my realm
[Music]
ugh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
your foolishness has brought you to this
end
take my blood and choke on it death
to the outsiders i'll turn your world
upside down
you are not prepared
[Music]
there is justice within the light
but you have to be patient
now pray with me
may akharat guide and protect me
may akarat guide and protect
me may he shepherd my soul
may he shepherd my soul
and grant it mercy
and granted mercy what are you
doing here this is not the time
but this is confession
and i have sinned
i was a thief who stole
from those more fortunate
i strayed from your light and
found my trade in the shadows
they call it murder
i say job well
done
i am a thief a heretic
a murderer father
will akara save me
you mark our light
but those monsters with a scourge upon
my frog
and you
oh you were the answer to their prayers
then we are settled and you owe me
the name you seek is
thank the heavens for you
heavens i assure you father
the heavens didn't send me
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a wanderer
don't do it
[Applause]
[Music]
though this be our focus tower it may
yet be your greatest moment
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
[Music]
not even them
you